[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par une nouvelle pour les communes qui
ont été touchées par les émeutes de
juillet dernier oui Mathilde et le
gouvernement veut clore cette séquence
Matignon a annoncé que ellisabeth B
présentera à la fin du mois les réponses
au Mair des villes les plus touchés par
les émeutes 500 édiles seront conviés à
noter qu'aujourd'hui un conseil
nationale de la refondation consacrée à
ce sujet a été présidé en fin de journée
par la première ministre en présence
d'une cinquantaine de personnalités
parmi eux un ivelinoir Raphaël cogier
mer de Man la jolie à guillancour le
maire François Morton a annoncé une
prime exceptionnelle pour ses agents oui
une prime à l'or de 300 à 800 € brut
selon la rémunération des agents les
raisons évoqué le pouvoir d'achat dans
un communiqué François Morton annonce
que 600 agents municipaux sont concernés
ce dont la rémunération mensuelle brut
ne dépasse pas les 3250 € brut montant
global 410000 € la prime a été votée à
l'unanimité le 3 octobre dernier à
l'occasion du dernier conseil municipal
et on termine ces informations Gabriel
par un rally oui un rally celui des
classes défens ce jeudi au Camp des
Loges de Saint-Germain en lait cinq
classes ont fait leur rally d'entrée par
rally comprenait un moment d'échange
entre militaire et élèves cinq classes
dont quatre de Saint-Germain en lait ont
pu découvrir les soldats de l'opération
sentinelle les différents métiers qui
composent l'armée ou encore assister à
une démonstration cinophile ce projet
pédagogique concerne des cl de collège
et de lycée pariné par une unité
militaire pour faire le lien armée
jeunesse les militaires sont amenés à
faire des échanges au sein même des
classes et les élèves à participer à des
cérémonies et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news